these are not so I go like this
is she over like that she should walk
out okay so no I come here and I let her
through you see Hey oh I come in there
and I take her vase don't get you don't
do this and then they fall down I should
walk out okay so maybe it goes here
right and then you go to here
learn learn follow through follow
through there look oh can you walk out
yeah you can you see I have to learn
follow through okay
saving here I miss the fight you missed
right you have to figure out how to do
it
okay let's go so we're not doing this
case right I don't want to give my in
the queue and he goes attention I'll get
and then he takes let's take advantage
of actually understanding all of the
little adjustments that we do that make
me have to adjust my technique to get it
and then as I am faced now with the
bouquet who's not a dressage pony let's
monitor my emotional content is it
triggering me or am I just accepting
what's happening because what you'll
tend to see is that once you're too
giggles like that he wants out then
you're gonna go like this
and you don't need to you just keep
doing micro adjustments see I'm doing
that I don't have to panic
[Music]
hey let's go
working and they teach me the other
now you're forcing the Newports move out
now you're tired you're sure enough so
let's see hi gorge
where you're of adapted I make that work
yeah had to go low if you started
sneaking on me right yeah constantly it
down
partly broken scent so I can't go like
that she'll walk out
so I lower it always adapting she was up
it's time to work on the skill of self
detachment self reconciliation and it's
not sparring it's that opportunity is
the opportunity where you cultivate it
but it's temporary
it just shows up every once in a while
okay so it's important for sukiya to
help that thing show up more and more
and more okay that opportunity so I come
in and I'm gonna do my thing but yeah
that was it but he didn't he's not a
stop on that was my tension dogging it
didn't work okay you're not supposed to
have
and this case don't worry he doesn't
really have my center he thought we got
a little greedy see
this is where it showed up again and
it's not there 200 damn
I thought if I go like this this is not
G uh sir you do not need finishing for
that so I start right see he didn't he's
not following but look what I'm doing
you see I'm adjusting and the
adjustments are happening very tiny very
tiny look on attorney you see no idea
where you force him down right what
he chose not to fall don't fall don't
fall what makes you fall that turn on
the head this turn right here right so
that's that's what's happening you just
can't skip but I'll feel the technique
cop is compromised right there
you say it's compromised so in a little
it's compromised boom I'll do it for
energy to come back the other way
don't fall don't fall hello do you see
oh ok right let's go
what you guys spotted when you saw me
throwing him you thought I'd
overpowering him I'm not I'm not
overpowering it see that that was the
cue that that's the wrong angle so look
over here you see filled out Virginia so
you just you go and you hit her face and
you go here
it's not this
that's the cute wrong place wrong place
at this speed you're looking for always
you see look at that wait right there
[Music]
right there
okay no rider coming around then you're
right here you see that you filled up
okay so I go around
this piece i reconcile every contention
point everything tension for later he's
pushing on me and let it go this one and
that is where the G was that captain
wolf attention
hey let's go okay so you guys are going
into this church that's turning loose -
yeah I mean should they come around here
and the eye turns on me you see like
that your opportunity for what we're
looking for is before that point so when
you to come in here and you're doing the
technique how you control his arm it's
going to be how much turning it and
where it is in relation to you because
this is not good
you see that so I would go it doesn't
matter so whatever you are he's trying
to turn but I'm controlling it I feel
him trying to turn but I didn't inside
his Center and he can turn what you guys
have been say him for he comes Indian
doesn't matter if long though he's
trying to do all that stuff
it's just I'm now micro adjusting the
technique you get it same thing goes
here on the face you control that okay
and OH
whenever you can't do it oh you see that
do you guys see that
that's your guilty - do you see it not
that technique so you're coming along oh
you're like oh
then don't look at less they usually put
a he turns on you look take the
other hand use public ash to take the
other hat or the easiest one is to take
his center because look if he comes up
on one leg he turn you he's got all this
pivot range and that's what's giving you
problems when you stay at the ends so
you're like over here you see at the end
come in right through the center
displace the center full center that
geometry up to dimensions
rotate the thing okay I'm going here
yeah let's go there's if you predict the
opportunity for cultivating self
detachment it's not there you're wasting
training time do you get that right okay
so I don't she pushes she's pushing me I
feeling everything she's doing
[Music]
you feel me pulling it not them you're
falling then you going like this so I
stay with zero pressure zero pressure
you get it no I don't want plus one
pressure here on I also don't want plus
one pressure here okay I'm staying
neutral neutral neutral neutral
all right yeah I feel that so I know I
don't push anyway
and my technique is disappear every
contestation she's half me you
understand so every time I construct the
compensation that's where the self
detachment is being cultivated in
practice you understand that so you're
you're wasting the training okay they're
gonna push on you that means you're
pushing on them so let go of that
neutralize that then the other opening
will show itself it will you don't have
to look for it okay if you go to the
next contention point that's you again
self manifesting let go of that point
okay let's go don't just fall down
[Music]
that's it
don't eat your strikes not a magic power
deviate make it work follow through make
everything
watch your head lower yourself
starting over Mary over
yes or not tomorrow
these are not so I go like this and she
goes like that she should walk out okay
so I come here and I let her through you
see time Hey oh I come in there and I
take her vase don't get you don't do
this and then they fall down
I shouldn't walk out okay so maybe it
goes here right and then you go to here
learn learn follow through follow
through now look
oh can you walk out yeah you can you see
I have to learn follow through okay
saving here I miss the fight you missed
right you have to figure out how to do
it
Thanks
lower your face and you will go down
look at me
[Music]
Hey 10 to everything without having to
see that dream get up
look you just gotta have to do follow
through same exact move and you don't
like your can be surprised that's the
Pablo come on no I'm doing the same food
same exact moves this controlling his
body
you see I lowered Oh
draw place big see like this see how you
breaking Center
you broke sent boom
okay let's go go right-center
[Music]
you can't stop by
lower it down now get up
that's terrible campaign
lower your body like you're gonna fire
you
[Music]
there's the line
there's a line three let's go you're
Sean you're trying to improve
[Music]
right I don't want to give my in the
queue and he goes attention I'll get her
and then he takes let's take advantage
of actually understanding all of the
little adjustments that do that make me
have to adjust my technique to get it
and then as I am faced now with it okay
he's not a dressage pony let's monitor
my emotional content is it triggering me
or am I just accepting what's happening
because what you'll tend to see is that
once you're it giggles like that he
walks out then you're gonna go like this
and you don't need to you just keep
doing micro adjustments see I'm doing
that I don't have to panic
[Music]
hey let's go take bit too much Maya
keep working that can teach me the other
job
trying to keep the same tempo the same
intensity changing that Bobby you beat
trigger do not ask me
[Music]
Xiao Yue of course even before sundown
that's how you're tired you're sure
enough so I think hi gorge
where you're of adapted I make that work
ahead to go low if you started snooping
on me right yeah constantly it down
the other party broken center so I can't
go like that she'll walk out
so I lower it always adapting
[Music]
so she was up it's time to work on the
skill of self detachment itself
reconciliation and it's not sparring
it's that opportunity is the opportunity
where you cultivate it but it's
temporary
it just shows up every once in a while
okay
so it's important for us to get to help
that thing show up more and more and
more okay that opportunity so I come in
and I'm going to do my thing but yeah
that was it but he didn't he got a stop
on that was my tension on it it didn't
work okay you're not supposed to have
done
and this case don't worry he doesn't
really have my center he thought we got
a little light reading
that's where it showed up again and it's
not there
200 damn I thought if I go like this
this is not G it wasn't you do not need
finishing for that so I start right see
he didn't he's not following look what
I'm doing
you see I'm gonna just me and the
adjustments are happening very tiny very
tiny look on turning you see not here
where you force him down right what
he's hot his jobs not to fall don't fall
don't fall what made you fall that's
right on the head this turn right here
right so that's that's what's happening
you just can't spin but I'll feel the
technique cop is compromised right there
you say it's compromised so in a little
it's compromised boom I'll do it for
energy to come back out of the way don't
fall don't fall hello do you see oh ok
right let's go
[Music]
yes go finish to their technique
don't fall okay oh gosh what is that oh
my gosh change partners burner try
harder don't fall
[Music]
go round it
energy but you guys started when you saw
me throwing him you thought I'd
overpowering him I'm not I'm not
overpowering then see that that was the
cue that that's the wrong angle so look
over here you see the field of Virginia
so you just you go and you hit her face
and you go here it's not this
that's the cute wrong place wrong place
at this speed you're looking for always
you see look at that wait right there
[Music]
right there see
okay No right you're coming around then
you're right here do you see that you
filled up okay so I go around
this piece I reconciled every contention
point every contention boiler he's
pushing on me and let it go this way and
that is where the G was us happen Wolf's
attention
Hey look for zero contention I reconcile
the contention points and that the speed
of light don't confuse the demonstration
with what you're doing
[Music]
the lowering yes he wants to go down let
him go down
turn up sound good you're missing your
Santa going to her Saturn on her armpit
if it's too happy that's what you can
tell you it yes don't pick the technique
he didn't want to go there you want to
go there
lower the hand in the head little lower
tighten up push through don't put your
hand on the back head keep your basic
good it'll pass you
[Music]
don't just fall down road I try not to
fall down then you generate the
opportunity you got to go to where it
balances thumb please fall on it then
make a tighter circle you're just
forcing an opportunity lost
where is he what a coat he want to go
down did you feel the heart of us we
think I'm gonna go back right so then he
goes down if you lower your center and
you're connected to his mentor this
venture will lower mouth
hey when my brother my head there it was
ahead but if you guys didn't know but
I'm not just resting on down okay go
to the line you gotta get in the shukaku
it's not in you've got a bigger guys
that's gonna grab you can't be standing
them on the line in front of them I
don't want that that's not what I got
happen
that's where fake coulda gonna happen
wherever you kid jumps over or that high
break fall that you try that on somebody
who wants to kill you and they're going
to kill you you don't stand in front of
them like that go
you must manipulate the arms so that
they cannot turn on you lower it rain
stop falling
thanks harder okay so that's turning
loose yeah yeah I mean they come around
here and the eye turns on me you see
like that you're an opportunity for what
we're looking for is before that point
so when you're coming here and you're
doing the technique how you control his
arm it's going to be how much turning it
and where it is in relation to you
because this is not good
you see that so it doesn't matter so
wherever you are
he's trying to turn but I'm controlling
it
I feel him trying to turn but I am
inside his Center and he can turn what
you guys have mistaken for he comes in
he doesn't not grateful no he's trying
to do all that stuff
it's just I'm now micro adjusting the
technique you get it
same thing goes here on the face you
control that okay and oh whenever you
can't do it oh you see that you guys see
that
that's your yoke agility is healed you
see if not that technique so you're
coming along oh god you're like oh
then don't look at let's say usually put
a he charms on you look take the
other hand use publish to take the other
half or the easiest one is to take his
center because look is he comes up on
one leg he turn you he's got all this
pivot range and that's what's giving you
problems when you stay at the ends so
you're like over here you see at the end
come in right through the center
displace the center mold Center that
geometry up to dimensions
rotate the thing and okay I'm gonna take
advantage of the opportunity to let go
and it out
[Music]
okay through the center keep the fight
go get your legs or kick you
that's good burner get up it's on Shing
you're not in the fight you're all out
of that okay good
[Music]
come on find a center don't just pull
his ends that's a lot of weight
[Music]
this ball good ball last you can adapt
these strike to the face lower it lower
it lower everything's get off the lie
and you're forcing it go around you're
forcing it
[Music]
oh that's predicting theirs if you
predict the opportunity for cultivating
self detachment it's not there you're
wasting training time do you get that
right okay so I don't she pushes she's
pushing me I feeling everything she's
doing
[Music]
hey hey Marshall Archie
better
oh you're pulling Oh you're picky
[Music]
you're pulling his right you're pulling
your right hand don't pull the right
hand don't hold the hand you feel me
pulling it nothing you're falling in you
going like this so I stay with zero
pressure zero pressure you get it no I
don't want plus one pressure here on I
also don't want plus one pressure here
okay I'm staying neutral neutral neutral
neutral
alright yeah I feel that so I don't I
don't push anyone then my technique is
disappear follow them
[Music]
so every contestation she's half me you
understand me so every time I construct
the content station that's where the
self detachment is being cultivated and
rocklers you understand that so you're
wasting the training okay they're gonna
push on you that means you're pushing on
them so let go of that your choice now
then the other opening will show itself
it will so you don't have to look for it
okay if you go to the next contention
point that's you again self manifesting
let go of that point okay let's go
don't just fall don't just fall push
through zero prices not jump did you
feel that in your hand because you're
lifting on it where do you feel then
wait hey stop where do you feel them so
now you don't feel them anywhere be
honest just get back into the technique
where do you feel the weight knocked at
your elbow really okay yeah at your
elbow it's because you're standing there
look if you move this and you go up up
up no your hand your hands free to go
and you move your body look here give me
enough position you see I cutie but look
if I come around like that you see how
it stops you see that and now I'm look
at me that just happens in in an instant
boom I'm over here
okay come on you can y'all know you
wanna keep on that's just a beginner
learning curve but in gu you're gonna
just stop the training hey
[Music]
eight stop do you look like a giraffe
drinking water okay
bend your knees get your mind up and out
[Music]
you're falling it
hi that's it